we're all some pretty [__] done dumb
Apes just floating through a rock
through space Apes have a good they
stopped at the right time Evolution wise
I think they're they're chilling oh I
have a great time
well they get to have all the you know
that orangutan or to drive that golf
cart in that one video and he didn't
have to get a license
you know he didn't have to go to the DMV
I think he got the best part of
evolution which is like sit back relax
eat bananas chill out they can get to
drive a golf cart dude I'm just jealous
they get to flick their turds without
any repercussions man like I I wish
that's my Dark Souls we should have
stopped at dogs dogs I'm just I I don't
think we evolved it doesn't matter
evolution is it a world of dogs
stop that dogs man Council of dogs is
this nothing more pure than just a dog I
think a dog
if the world was only dogs would dogs be
friendly to each other I don't think
they would
yeah maybe the reason why dogs ended up
evolving is wholesome and awesome as
they did is because of the filthy human
dogs just agree we tampered and it
worked for once
that was when it was we did a massive W
for once what about cats
they do they they already own the world
let's pull the strings from those
Shadows
can't live in their world yeah what do
you mean it's since the beginning of the
Egyptian age we've worshiped [__]
cats yeah I wonder what it is about cats
that we just we can't help but just
gravitate towards since ancient times
Humanity has not changed they're cute
cats could be like the biggest [__]
[__] in the world and humans are
like I [__] love you and I would die
for you and they are completely right
cats cats are literally the same humans
do that to other humans you're a giant
piece of [__] but I love you
cats are basically the cigarettes of the
animal world they're just like I know
this thing is absolutely horrible but
God damn I can't stop I can't stop I I
uh when I was at Ludwig's house I got to
stroke uh Coots and that was a very cute
kiss
I thought that sentence
I I did get to do that too I was lying
down and then Coots would just jump on
me and he would just want you know a
good cuddling I thought all right yeah
okay I'll allow it I've allowed you to
exist we uh we have this uh we have this
cat uh in my house in England uh that's
yeah I remember yeah that's not our cat
it's our neighbor's cat oh okay but it's
really our cat okay it's the streets cat
we don't know what her name is uh for
some reason Sydney's Sydney uh named her
Scarlett Joe and then that name just
stuck because whenever she shouts it the
cat just comes running so I don't know
what what your cat's name is uh sorry uh
Mrs neighbor but uh it's Scarlet Joe now
um and this is Appropriations in there
yeah this she she she's too [__]
smart man because she knows okay here's
the thing right we we're we're simple
creatures we just want to give them pets
and give them love right they they're
cats we just want to give them pets and
give them love
um Scarlet Joe knows the exact right
amount of pets that she's willing to
give before like saying no no more pets
you're not allowed anymore right and
then and then she knows that we [__]
crave it so like anytime
anytime
anytime we look like we're like you know
a bit more disinterested than usual she
goes now have a pet and we're like [__]
are you are you giving me a pet and she
and she just lets us pet her and she
goes all right enough I'm like [__] I
want to pay you more now I want to pay
you more so she is in full control [__]
I I know the worst thing is I know she
is but I can't stop it okay okay if she
if she wants pets I'm going to give it
to her and God [__] damn it like it's
just I'm telling you man like cute
animals are just like they just get the
pass she's an evil [__] being
she's evil man she she's a manipulative
evil [__] being I believe that God
and you know what but I love her
I'm this close to [__] abducting her
from our neighbors man who needs to she
was coming to you yes yeah exactly she
is when when she knows when we're when
uh
when we haven't been uh when we've come
back from like a long trip from like
Japan or something like that the first
day every first day she's always like so
loving so everything we feel loved we
feel like we're back over then every
other day after that she just goes back
to normal all right you've had your time
now I'm just gonna I'm just gonna sit
here and just judge you I don't want to
give you too much sir yeah yeah no no
more serotonin for you sir
oh man what was your cat like when you
grew up because you yeah I had a few
cats
um a few yeah wow yeah we had well when
I was born we had two
um but like my my parents had three the
whole time uh Pocky and little guy
um it was it was weird because it's like
when you have two cats living in the
same house it you really see the
personality differences right right
because like when you just see a cat by
itself it's like okay you know you can
discern maybe some like personality
traits of the cat right the different
cats that you know but like when it's
two cats next to each other it really is
like night and day yeah so like I think
like I mean I don't remember a whole lot
because I was really young but like I
remember like little guy was definitely
the [__] in the family
um he would he would do this thing where
like I don't know if he had like memory
problems or whatever but like we would
feed him right and then literally 30
minutes later he'd come back and be like
where the [__] my food
I do that and just stop meowing at my
dad yeah and my dad's like [__] I've
just fed you leave me the [__] alone and
he just be like no I'm still hungry give
me my [__] food meanwhile Porky is
like out on The Veranda just being like
thank you for the meal father that was
absolutely delicious I'm going to saw
some of this stuff bro let me uh you
compare me now you can come and pay me
I'm full I'm satisfied come here though
me whole little guy's just being like
I'm still hungry give me my food where
is it and it's just I don't know like I
I loved both cats equally for like
different things but it's just like it
really does just show like how these
animals just have like really just
distinct personalities and it's like and
it's dope you know like you know like
even like when we had we used to have
like a lot of birds as well right like
my parents currently owned like a
cockatiel right now and like compared to
the last cockatiel we had this one is a
million times more of an [__] but
it's like but it's forgivable because
it's cute and the couple of times that
it falls asleep in your hand it's like
you know what all the bite marks you
gave me over the years
I think I've always wondered about birds
why don't they just fly away
what do you mean like what stopping them
just flying away oh I mean our last
cockatiel floor yeah right I think yeah
is there a point where the bird goes
hold on a second
fly and never come back or actually our
first our first cockatiel uh z uh he
actually flew away but then he flew into
because you know we live next to a
national park yeah he flew out but then
got confused to be like holy [__] where
am I because we could actually see him
circling around like trying to find us
and then what he ended up doing was he
just nosedived into the the the the the
forest and so my dad and I went out to
actually go and find him uh you know
hoping that he didn't fly off somewhere
yeah and after like a 20 minute search
we we heard him we could hear him
chirping and I looked up at this tree
and he's just like perched on top just
like looking down being like
[__] help me where the [__]
where am I the [__] have you been if I
saw the bird girl I'd be like yeah we're
not getting that yeah so the original
plan right was like my dad took off his
jacket and was just like all right call
him down like to know that we're here
and then the moment he like lands
anywhere I'm gonna put the jacket on top
and like wrap him up so he doesn't like
freak out and fly away somewhere right
so that was the original plan so like
we're calling him down he's like looking
down being like is it safe is it safe
and he he flies down he lands on the
shoulder but and as soon as my dad was
about to put the jacket on him I was
like no I don't think we should because
this [__] was gripping onto my
shoulders like no tomorrow it was like
it was hurting it's just like I am not
leaving your shoulder so what ended up
happening was it was like a 20 minute
walk back to the house yeah he just
[__] stayed there oh that's cool he
just didn't move he was just like take
me home right now please so like what
what the normal like why do birds not
fly away sometimes like why do they just
and do they ever come back if they like
well I think it depends on like how the
bird was raised so like if it was raised
in captivity its entire life then it
doesn't know the concept of flying away
uh okay right but if if it's say from
like you know you take it from like the
wild then obviously they're gonna be
more prone to be like why am I in this
[__] rooms like just fly away like
it's like Dad too and then just come
back you feel like a thing for like some
birds I have no idea how how it is to
own a boat as a pet I think I think I
think some birds yeah I mean it depends
obviously on how long you've like kept
oh it's like dogs as well right like
some dogs run away but then there are
accounts of a couple of days later the
dog just shows up in your front porch
and it's just like all right what did I
miss Karen do this time whereas like
some dogs just run away and you never
see them again right so I think it just
depends on like the attachment factor of
the animal yeah I guess dads do that too
so I guess you know it's not that's how
you need to do any of the birds of dogs
yeah yeah you need an AI to stop that
yeah I'm like oh yeah
like no all living creatures do that my
dad
yeah so it's like it was really
fascinating that like you know that like
even with but because you know I never
had that concept of like birds having
that idea right because I was kind of
the same as you when I first started
owning a bird of like oh we have to be
careful where every time they might just
[__] fly away or just like Scout
every [__] like crevice to the house
but then you know there are some places
where like uh you know you could like
interact with like an owl or like an
eagle or like a bigger Bird yeah and
they're not attached to anything but
they're just like chilling out and
they're just like they could fly away at
any time but they're just like nope you
know what um I like it here I think I'm
gonna stay here yeah yeah so it's
interesting I've I've never I've never
owned a bird before uh but I have seen
one grow up before this is this is just
a really weird story uh that this talk
has just reminded me of so when I was
living in Thailand uh my house in
Thailand is like over
is uh over like a pond and I kind of
think uh we have we have a pawn next to
our
Big Spender
I mean it's complex
it's Thailand okay we know we live we
live on like the Outsource of Bangkok so
it's like a bit more in nature
um and near like uh near the rooftop and
everything like that or just on the
balcony Birds would like like to make
nests and everything like that uh and so
in my office uh in Thailand I sit right
next to a window that has a really
really good view of the places uh of the
place where Birds would love to make
their nests and everything like that and
so one bird made a nest that was kind of
like right right next to my window uh
almost next to my window right
um so I I saw basically that a bird had
made a nest and like I saw that you know
she had laid some eggs and some babies
and some mice uh birds like some baby
birds have had had hatched and every day
I would come down and I would see the
mum feeding them and slowly and slowly
would see them like you know grow up and
I will never forget this point because I
I would I would see them every single
day I saw these little chicks grow up
and everything like that
um and there's a day where I saw their
first flight all right well I saw that
first flight and it was it was
interesting for me because I've never
seen how birds just learned to fly yeah
right uh initially I just thought okay
Instinct they just know how to fly
um nope they uh that that doesn't happen
actually yeah well at least that's not
what I saw
um so actually the mother hopes to teach
them how to fly right so what happens is
uh he's here's me like I'm sitting I'm
sitting on my window there's the nest is
over there and what happens is the
mother flies to like the little it flies
my window and it like chirps at the
Chiclets it's like come on come here
yeah I'm gonna teach you how to fly come
on come on come on you can do it you can
do it
um and initially uh and initially the
chick's like all right I can do this
immediately does it right
and then but then I think something just
clicked in in his brain to be like oh
that was scary actually that was I was
in the air and mind you between my
window and where the nest was was just
pawned it was just water right so if
they fall they're [__] drowning yeah
right and so the mother flies back to
the nest
and and she she continues chirping for
the chicklet to fly back to the nest
doesn't do it
one minute
one minute passes doesn't do it Mom
flies back flies through the nest again
chirps again
three minute passes doesn't do it the
chicklet looks at his mum and
and then after the mum chirped really
loudly this one time chicklet just
stands on the edge looks at his looks at
his mum
shits himself
I'm not joking get it confident I'm not
joking I'm looking at this bird his
mum's like chirping he shoots himself
and then he takes off and it's a low
takeoff and at this point I'm I'm
invested in this boat because I'm
thinking to myself if this bird falls in
yeah I'm running out of my office and
I'm diving into this Pawn to save this
bird yeah I see this bird growing up
this bird ain't dying on his first
flight and what happens is he takes off
but he's too low he's like flapping his
wings yeah and he what happens is the
nest is purged up there he hits uh he
hits the little balcony before the nest
yeah he like panicly like like tries to
grab on tries to grab on flaps his wing
I was like halfway through running out
but luckily he just got enough elevation
to get his foot on the nest and I was
like oh my [__] God I'm so [__]
proud of you man that's it I'm back with
my boy that's my boy right there man I'm
proud of him that's cute it's a cute
Story how to clean the budget off my
balcony you know you know that was it
was it was worth it yeah shits himself
Pursuits to fly
I just [__] the fear out of myself
[Laughter]
humans could do that
let me just shoot
I was like oh I'm good I'm empty ready
to go in that moment I realized Austin
birds were not so different when we Face
[__] When We Fear stuff we want to [__]
ourselves oh yeah not just Birds just do
it
commit you know they don't care they
just [__] themselves we say I'm shooting
myself the bird actually shits itself